does it worry bill that people are more
divided than ever that we've got this
kind of Left Right divide and the left
looks at the right and the right looks
at the left and no one seems to really
trust each other anymore
uh no I just don't think any of that's
real it's not real it's just saying the
people from England and around you guys
always ask these questions like what's
it like everybody yelling at each other
and walking around with a machine gun
and it's just like it's like you know
what I mean I'm trying to think of The
Stereotype of where you guys come from
it's just it's just not this it's it's
it's kind of you you are what they show
and what what everybody shows now is
heightened emotions because there's so
many places to look at things like crazy
gets people to stop and watch but like
actual you know people just chilling out
no one wants to see that they want to
see like fighting and that type of thing
so
um I know what you're saying but we've
been talking to people hey you've been
here for a week you got it down man
please by all means tell me about my
country
I'm just asking the question bill yeah
that's cool I answered it you think
you're still going back yeah but
according you know I know you guys are
gonna go back to England oh they're
[__] fat everybody's got a gun in the
visor of their car I know what you guys
are going to do you know actually
Americans are not that fat it's the fat
Americans who are extra fat most
Americans are the same as the British
well our food supply is poison yeah it
was taken over by one group of people
and they own the rights to the seeds and
all of that type of stuff and they
forced out all of these Farmers if their
seeds blew under their property they
could sue them for using their seeds and
the media just ignored all of that
because they get paid by them that's
sort of what is going on globally is
everybody's is just choosing money on
the bag is [__] kids say nowadays
um that's what the problem is nobody is
uh you know they're everybody's
screaming and yelling about [__] that
doesn't matter like stand-up comedians
they'll yell about that but they won't
talk about literally people uh poisoning
their own countrymen I mean they should
be [__] put to death for what they
did
there you go there's a hot take I mean I
know if I did it
shop and put
it puts a [__] donut
that hurts somebody or caused them to
have some sort of medical episode that
would be a I would not be sitting here
right now but they somehow you know you
know how it is Catholic Church can do
what they do
kind of move people around and uh
everything's all right as long as you
[__] you know you're paying people
it's good so
that's what it is
it's a great Point why is it do you
think that we get more obsessed by the
stuff that doesn't matter your pronouns
blah blah blah then the actually really
important stuff like the fact there's a
fentanyl crisis in this country because
you're being steered away from it
there's also money and and it's just
like you have to sacrifice
someone in on one of those big news
channels would have to sacrifice their
cushy life
and uh you know and fall on the knife
and nothing would happen I mean that's
what you probably learned with Snowden
what he did you know and like he did
that for all of us he should be treated
like a hero half of the people you know
over here the big thing is if you know
somebody's fighting for the people uh
they're immediately branded a socialist
or a communist
and they somehow try to tie him to uh
Putin
banking system's a little [__] up and
maybe uh it shouldn't be run by a
private Corporation could be that
um yeah
that you're being asked so much about
politics
there's a stand-up
uh no because I I just think that uh
you know they don't want real answers
they want idiots like me talking about
it and then everybody just go that's
just some idiot comedian that does [__]
jokes but they don't want like uh I
don't know I don't even think they even
answer the questions or even ask them
anymore I don't know it's getting
depressing